[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
this
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
what's going on guys
hold up
gotta make sure you guys can hear me
right what's going on guys
all right now you should be able to hear
me
i don't know why the capture card's in
there twice but we're gonna meet one of
them me get the chat up
as you can see
hold up my camera be bugging
i gotta raise it just a little bit
you shouldn't hear an echo anymore man
hold up
let me
go to display
i gotta get rid of discord man you're
going to hear that
thing we ain't trying to hear that
auto choppy
all right i'll fix it
look this is just testing with my new
setup man
that's all this is testing with my new
setup
what's choppy like me talking
what's what's choppy do i sound fine
does the game sound fun
what's going on guys i gotta
gotta hear more input man we gotta go
all right it should go away now because
i got red i turned it down
let me make sure
yeah so everything should be good
all right maybe now
maybe now you guys will be fine maybe
not
let's go ahead and go to deathly
[Music]
hold up
all right so what's going
should be taken on of
[Music]
[Music]
super
[Music]
all right what about now do i sound good
now what's going on man what's going on
how do i sound now
how do i sound man
[Music]
all right all right so so julian said
there you go perfect there we go man we
got this
10 out of 10.
man that's all you want to hear in life
man this stuff is a 10 out of 10.
uh so how you guys doing man
we about to play this death loop
[Music]
all right let's get into this
oh my god man
it's a good camera man
death loop automatically saves your
progress when you enter and exit
missions or change your loadout so i
can't change my loadout
and i'm not a uh so there's no saving
to do something to go out because
there's been a lot of that in previous
of these type of games where you could
just save your loadout and continue
going on where you were
they ain't letting you do that here so
so which okay so you have to uh play
online or julian and invade other
players all right so this is kind of
like invade other player things so right
now we're going to break the loop
because that's our only option
[Music]
one and a half hour mandatory overtime
but okay i'll fork tomorrow
oh for the last time oh they started
praying no if you just give me a second
no you're not even trying
oh
lady i have no idea
giving me nightmares already
oh
i think this is you start on the beach
every time i shoot
that was one
ridiculous night
oh i gotta stop drinking
okay
how the [ __ ] did i get here
oh no man all right so it's got the
the the classic
arcane display feels like an arcade game
got the sprinting
see hold up left dodge i wish it was the
right one the right
melee so we'll we'll consider that all
right so let's keep going here
break the break
oh something's wrong
that's probably a side effect of dying
nope that's there i'm seeing it ah man
okay so let's go here who are you who
who am i my name he's hallucinating man
this whole game you're actually on lsd
they just want something
[Music]
so you just woke up and don't know
what's happening hey you missed
oh great of course you would
let me turn down this um
let me turn down the
the little light i have above me because
oh my god i'm still gonna have to go to
the other screen
because like what's happening is like
this this light above me
is just too bright
i need to turn it down just to tear
why can't i turn it down
so let's turn it on
okay there we go now let's turn it down
to about
10
because i'm not trying to go blind
playing
death loop that would be horrible
there we go now that that feels better
on me
we chilling yeah we are chilling drunken
ninja what's up going on man
so first off i i gotta say the game
looks pretty pretty good
i like that dodge mechanic i don't
remember that being in and dishonored it
might have been
it's been long so long since i played
okay
be your best self
this place is mine
a personal ticker
what does it do shiny
makes me feel funny
personal to continuing everybody with
the power of black reeds temporal
anime with uh amplify your skills and
distributes while others enhance your
weapons higher quality tinkers have more
powerful effects speakers will be hidden
around black reef or taken from enemies
and equipped in between missions
interesting i like that concept i like
that concept we roll it man we roll it
charlie monkey
alright so i assume these are the people
that they want me to kill
i assume
i might be wrong though
all right let's go here
doctor willie g evans
brilliant science never stops working
chip on her shoulder never seen her
carrying a
well this is creepy
so let's open that
all right so
charlie
so i'm assuming these are the people we
supposed to go kill
there's a locked door there
let's pick this up
black black reef where the party
we're not even trying to pronounce okay
so that's how you hack stuff
uh target the device and hold l1 to hack
it the lights of that will display your
progress some hack devices can be
remotely triggered with the hack mac aim
at the hacked device and press l1 to do
so okay okay
all right so we got in here
you know the code no i didn't i don't
know anything
yo hello
what the
see i don't need a code i can i got the
hack backer whatever it's called
hey is my name colt
that's gotta be it right
okay i don't feel like a cult all right
colt let's go find this code
what's up hustle
oh i'm freezing i don't know if i was
supposed to do that but we did that
we're gonna move faster
what is that
so they're aware of the loop
yeah that doesn't sound good
okay all right so they're aware of the
of the loop so clearly something here
they're aware of that's going on
yeah the voice actor is so far solid man
so far
you could sneak
all right
executions r1 to prompt an execution
instantly killing aware
you can perform executions with our uh
with armed with a gun or bare-handed tip
i want to draw your machete
you move slightly when you're crouched
you trended okay
so just like a dishonored game
gotcha
oh
oh they just disappeared
that felt too easy i think it's because
they're not i've done this that's
probably why they're disappearing
because they're in a loop
yes you've done this before
i like how the game has humor
i like that
i don't know what those are
is death lip on the ps4 why can't i
remember
they'll be back
tomorrow oh my god that's kind of funny
all right let's look around look how
good this game looks man
i mean the water look kind of i mean
that's not water that's i still
feel like they could have made that look
a little bit better there's like no
animations going on down there
like the world is stiff
but i'm not really looking too much like
the the landscaping looks nice though
oh we hear people
people's around
prepare yourself
okay do i jump over this
focus okay so i was trying to to look
no gs ps5 that's cool
all right uh so press tag an enemy
marking them on your screen when you get
the type of weapon they carry that's
that's nifty keep holding the focus
reveal morbidity such as combat
tendencies their awareness and hints as
to what kind of loot they may be looking
for
it turns with the predictive gear
visibility radio power use your focus to
learn more about them okay so we got a
focus ability
so he's got a machete
something going on over there we ain't
nowhere close to being there though so
we ain't going over
there hold up
i feel like i can assassinate him but
that's not the right thing to do oh no
they're telling me to
while in the air press everyone to drop
your toe
that didn't work the way it was supposed
to
do they hear it
no i think we good i think we good
they hear nothing
we're not going that way there's three
of them with one of us
so they disappear so there's no hiding
dead bodies i like that
all right we're not going that way we
might have to go that way
i wonder if i can do something with this
card it caused like a commotion
no you can't
what is that oh it's just that
i guess we're just gonna have to take
them
take them out man
is there anything we can hack
yep
what is this gonna do
college disturbance
oh
what's up
one of these had a gun
you have a pistol
where am i coming from left right left
right wrong
that was that was very satisfying
hello hello hello
where's the gun
okay look i don't know what i did last
night where is the gun if you could just
uh
uh
i think we know each other we know each
other don't
how much do you we about well for some
reason this is in my controller and out
of my ears do you remember my name's
colt about me you want to kill me for
some reason and i already know some
[ __ ] code which i don't and this is
wanna break the loop right oh yeah i
think so
if you don't try to break the loop i'm
just going to kill you over and over
again in increasingly violent ways until
you're fine i'll break your [ __ ] loop
and whatever i didn't piss you off i'm
sorry all right so i don't like how that
was played on the controller because i
missed some of that conversation
go inside the library where is a gun
i'm not feeling that they said there was
a gun there and it's not letting me pick
one up i'm good a fist-pump
i don't know what that oh that's for
your health okay
can you break these
don't trust her
all right we're not going to trust her
we're going to look for a different way
in if we can find one
there might not be a different way in
this might be part of the story
okay okay okay don't get so bossy
help stations where's the hell station
what do they look like
okay so it's oh yeah this right here
i didn't really take any damage i don't
really need it
you can change the audio in the settings
maybe let's try that real quick
audio
controller speaker no
good good lookout nine good lookout man
that was mad annoying i'm glad they let
me change it
gotta let you guys here too
so candy
what kind of candy is this is it let me
eat it no
so it's
literally just wasting it
that's kind of
that's kind of interesting
candy with no
use of the actual candy
break the loop
so this this is the library
hold up
where's home girl all right
i'm in the library whatever you do no
we're not don't pull the letter okay
where's the lever hello we're pulling
the lever because she showed us not to
where is oh
should we pull the lever chat
i'm feeling like we should pull the
lever
i want to pull the lever i'm gonna look
around
but i feel like we should pull that
lever
today's guesstimations will nightmare
his lucky jacket tries to drink from the
bottle oh that's cool
that's cool
also we're locked in now
we are locked in so let's pull the lever
oh [ __ ] what
just once please can you try try your
hardest to make this interesting
what the [ __ ] is this
you're gonna give me that attitude you
know i usually make it easy for you you
ungrateful prick she is mean
this time i'll let you see yourself out
[Music]
yup we did it
ah
all right so
don't tell her well i don't i don't have
anything to tell her so
i think we're good on that
jump
play back jump jump you'll survive
i feel like they're trolling me chad
i feel like if i jump out here we gonna
die
but who cares no jump
i bet you slide
oh okay okay here goes
they trolling me they gotta be trolling
me
there's no way i survived this there's
no way
oh well
you gotta be [ __ ] me
what is going on listen to me
you wrote it on black brief you already
know the code what the [ __ ] does that
mean hello are you dead yet
hold me up
the postcard dumb ass you wrote it on
the black reef postcard understand okay
i'm gonna drop you man no wait the [ __ ]
this game is crazy that's a crazy way to
start this
i'm back at the beginning man i'm back
at the beginning
[Music]
okay
postcard postcard get the postcard get
off the speech
postcard where's the postcard
postcards up there
break the loop
okay
yeah all right so let's do this again
same morning
we ain't
oh he threw the postcard away
you gotta be kidding me
four two three zero suppose all right
let's uh
break some loops
you are never
ever going to
you don't want me to break it what do
you want from me i want you
to not suck okay it's been a pretty
shitty morning or two so i'm done
the versatile explosive with three
grenade proximity
charge and trip mine
grenades you press that to throw pr
press l1 to throw the charge or hold l1
to cook it before you release it so you
just press it once press i want to start
trying to surface
and press one to place it
announcement
go back and get your gun
i didn't even see a gun
i don't need a gun how about that i
don't need a gun
i'm gonna do everything myself man
i don't have
why would someone put this
whoa
what the [ __ ]
what is that
okay
the mysterious piece of metal seems to
belong to you a slab
it grants you reproducibility which
allows you to return to life after you
die but only twice
alright so there is a mechanic in here
for you to return to life that's
interesting
after return reprise you're almost
invincible for a few seconds use this
opportunity to get out of harm's way
the number of times you can return and
reprise resets when you travel between
distances
okay okay
here goes
daybreak
this is this it's so far so good man
so far so good
uh lord roughness this game this looks
like an xbox game i don't know about
that daybreak so we
survived daybreak let me raise my chair
a little bit let me raise my chair a
little bit it's a little
difficult to raise the chair a little
bit but we're gonna raise it a little
bit there we go
so i survived daybreak
daybreak has been defeated
uh
you've got a gun so i somehow i do have
a gun whoever said for me to go get a
gun i do have a gun so you was wrong i
want to point that out
a fistful of grenades and an address is
some place called updan now go get
yourself some answers
all right
so we got this gun this is the gun that
we got and we got two tricketts
welcome to death flute here are a few
tips to get you started
lee uh leads track the information you
have found it will be further colts
uh coats go of breaking the loop and
escaping blackwell
check out the leads you've discovered
move more okay so here's the leads
find my up down flat my mo
my mail goes to an address and up down
i'm allowed to open my eyes
i'm allowed to open my own mail even if
i don't know who i am right that's funny
i like that
return to the mission so we have to go
back
it's dangerous out there you want to
make sure you're carrying the best
weapons and items
so let's go to the loadout
downloaded items will become available
after completing the longest day i don't
know what the longest day is
there are slots that slab strange
objects that provide potent and unusable
abilities currently you have reprise
that's the one where you come back to
life i assume
colt's personal slab which gives him a
second and third chance after dying
kill visionaries and swipe their slabs
equipped and upgrade them here
all right so we have trick it here
so we have a spring hill double jump in
the air class maneuver we need that
that's always something that's good
we have a gun it says you can modify it
yeah we'll go ahead and modify it all
right
explore up down wherever that is
raiden blade i'm at work
want to watch but have two more patients
to see how long are you streaming for
look man as long as the game keeps me
entertained i got a gatorade zero here
and i got one back there on my bed so
i'm good for a little bit i do got the
attic
and shower always act so surprised like
i wouldn't know exactly where you're
going i don't even know where i'm going
is down the road let me
play your way enemies travel can be
dealt with fairy waves combat evasion
stealth and trickery all approach quiet
wait for a conversation to finish in
order to isolate your enemies and
uh potentially pick up new information
sounds like you're angling for an invite
i like how
i like this jacket
now i don't want to just start shooting
let's make sure there's no one up here
with them
snap that net
[Music]
bottles are portable noisemakers okay so
let's grab the bottle
so we want to go there
let's go down a little bit
waste [ __ ] time
all right so we got in here
all right let's see
you
not
crazy
the festivities tonight so get outside
and have some fun today
oh this is
so that i assume
these are things that they can mess me
up with
some cameras of some sort but i'm
assuming i can also
hack the camera
she thinks she's the
all hunter so let's just walk
what's going on here
kill them all kill them
then kill more
all right so i'm not a sociopath i don't
have to listen to her
i don't
yeah there's definitely people up there
i don't know how i feel about that
all right so we're not going that way
i do feel like if i try to take him down
he's gonna notice
already got full ammo
i don't want to shoot either i wish
there's some form of
of uh silence ammo but we go oh no
that's not a bottle
they're everywhere
they'll blast your ass who
i do hear a robot of some sort
oh that's that um
okay
she loves the view she loved the view so
that's a past tense kind of curious why
they spoke like that
what is this
oh
the neck brakes are just mean
oh
squeeze
yeah i want to hold reload okay
swapping guns
i like that let's get this too no
kill them all i'm only killing people i
have to i'm not killing everyone this is
supposed to be my place kind of tight
all right what is this
spicy
wow
pretty
handwritten never give up lila
never give up live okay
i won't
temporarily group check
private messages
you still up listening up to a round
nervous about midnight it will be fine
i've done it before remember our badass
captain just got back from a complex
yeah walked up
pretty amazing despite all the
infrastructure the entire loop has flown
from the controller i complement people
all the time
so the loops
you finished in up time for now your
next steps the complex you can continue
to explore or head next or head for the
exit you have to complete uh you have
plenty of opportunity to return to up
down later so don't feel like you have
to explore every nuke and cranny at this
moment if you die before you leave this
joshua restart the loop losing any
weapon or trigger you've collected since
entering up damn how uh however coates
learned what he needed to know here so
you immediately progress to the location
of your next goal the control room
this is too easy
way too easy
uh charlie runs the minimum network
gotta trick it
you were never uh you were loved once
this this has a weird meeting i've been
feeling the story about to be deep
it's a shame this doesn't have a
silencer on i could do some serious
damage
another [ __ ] code i don't have
another code
dual welding
useful for redecorating
or silent head shots with pneumatic
prejudice silent headshots there we go
nails
all right
try to get past me
all right so i definitely like the
silent headshot nail gun
that's helpful
we had a grenade we can do well too
so that's helpful
is there a map
now
i assume i got to go back the way i came
keywords headshot look man
when they don't expect it you could get
those headshots pretty well there my
friend
hold up
nothing
i'm no i don't feel comfortable there's
a lot of people over there
[Music]
i should probably do more looks
hackable signal
no i don't need to hack anything
man you guys are fighting with chris
hart already
no need to fight with chris hart he
knows he lost
all right let's see if there's uh
there was two dudes here earlier
yeah so there's still two dudes okay i
want to try to
oh
that that that was a fail
oh i don't feel comfortable being on the
ground i'd rather be on the rooftops
i'd rather be on the rooftops
i probably couldn't go too far on the
rooftops anyway looks like there's a
plus map access to our collection of
premium weapons
oh there's no you are here thing that
would have been nice
[Music]
taking these boys out why you guys want
me to be all like
like all centric and stuff laura how
does the dual sense controller feel when
twisting next i don't look let me let me
let me twist one more neck and then i'll
tell you
i don't know how it feels yet
i haven't twisted the neck those tunnels
run underneath this entire island
that's how i'm getting to the complex
let's blow this joint
all right there we go
yeah that's my that's my uh
that's how i want to play the game is
dishonored but uh so far so good
i like how they took what they what they
usually do well and they did
better with it if that makes sense to
you guys
i survived
complete the control of the complex so
that's me going uh to another one
i got a map a map that doesn't tell me
where i'm at by the
way i got two guns this spiker is going
to be really helpful
trick is collected uh after
inflict reduce damage but re uh suffer
reduce damage
so i assume time has went through
over uh changes over the time here you
can review the opportunities and secrets
you discovered in this district in this
pacific time period
you can also learn more about the
vulnerability visionary frequently the
area
uh select any objective with the man
icon to track it with the marker uh let
me read the chat a little bit
uh so maddie is simply
he wants to look if maddie likes
dishonored and he wants to play this
game like like he wants it to play like
a dishonored game i can't front him on
that like because i lowkey wanted to
play like a dishonored game and it plays
like a dishonored game
i think it does play like dishonored
there's a lot of similarities between
this and dishonored
on black free knowledge this power quote
remembers everything that you discovered
on the island and those discoveries are
recorded here discoveries are organized
into time periods and districts to apply
to in to which they apply
select any discovery with a diamond
marker icon to enable a an in-game
marker to help you guide you to the
subject of discovery for the discover
related specifically to breaking the
loop or discovering special equipment
refer to the visionary lead menu on the
arsenal leads menu
okay so let's see what this is up down
so that's the map
i still gotta figure out how to use this
map
it is a unique experience i'll give you
that
charlie runs the midcom network okay i
don't know who charlie is yet
we haven't been to the complex yet
pick your loader here weapon slabs and
trickets you have collected weapons are
on the left okay
so so far so good
we haven't picked up any more of these
special abilities
but i do like this so i'm gonna go with
this
and maybe this pistol i wonder if you
could turn it into some form of a um
i'd like if you could turn it into a
if you could turn it into a silenced
weapon somehow
people buying ps5s and droves to play
this it's a good game man like i don't
so far
maybe it's not worth to go out and buy
an entire ps5
but if you have one
i am getting i give approximately zero
[ __ ] about what you call yourself
once you used to be friends
so that's why you told everyone to kill
me but i'm the only one talking to you
so what does that tell you that i hang
out with the wrong people all right
control center
shut down
uh
i thought i had that let me go back no
okay no never mind it's
i don't want that to be
hold up
oh my god
okay can i switch these hold up
i gotta switch these man i don't know
how you do it though
i don't think you can
i don't think you can
oh there we go
gotta have that man gotta have that
your head down
you don't got to tell me twice okay
here's that giant fan
i don't know what this is a view to die
for
what's up will scream
no game deserves to have a console ball
for i have to disagree man there's games
that i would definitely
whoa what's going on
games that i would buy a console for
what is going on watch out
not this way
controls are in another bunker
he's like yo you're going the wrong way
man you're going the wrong way
we're going to listen to the game we're
going to go a different way
what's going on snoozy look at i don't
know what's going on right now all right
i'm just going with the flow right now
i got my little nail gun
oh
i think someone saw that
it's okay though it's okay i'm not
stressed
oh
oh yeah they disappear so it's kind of
impossible for them to see it
i don't unless they see the dead body
like directly in front of them
there we go some headshots look man
everything is below
[Music]
i haven't played the pc version all
right so there is three people here and
it looks like there is a
a security system
we want to be very careful here
so let's get this
[Music]
all right come on
[Music]
how did you see that
oh my god this thing is
all right so i think that's everyone
i think
i don't know though
i think that's everyone
shoot them all i shot them all
what is this
what's going on
a lever
it's unpowered so we have to turn the
power on somehow
tickets is
follow for fun i was hoping to perform
some actual scientific testing
okay got to be a switch
around here somewhere
hello
well what's up
the situation is under control
cult
is that you
no
[ __ ]
all right so i assume we don't have long
oh this looks like it does something
important what the
[Music]
what's going on
[Music]
oh you gotta be kidding me so what a
battery device
i like coat man i like coat
where's the battery
all right so you do charge these
batteries
the gameplay
so far so good man the gameplay so far
so good
okay
juiced show me what you can do
he knows everything
i don't like that it should
it's a projector
i don't agree with that
i feel like that could be fixed i feel
like that could be better
that's just me though
projector shouldn't be able to project
through me
come on
arcane studios
all right so we do everything he said
lpp
sounds
powerful could do some damage what are
these guys
what is this
shotgun shell nope i'm good
don't get greedy cold
up let's see
i haven't really spent any ammo to be
honest with you and if that's usually
some kind of currency it's a little
upset
um
let's go outside
oh
it's not green
okay
i think this is just another way inside
i don't know maybe it's not
we did go out the back door
can you get on this ice
can i see the
i wish i had a map
oh my god this is this is making me very
nervous
[Music]
oh they know where i am
let's go
[Music]
i don't care about your friends
all right now let's get them
oh
got a lot of ammo maybe they should have
should have adjusted that a little bit i
think we got too much ammo
uh so far so good
james so far so good
i think i just came here today
yeah i did
it's got to be a
different way
i'm missing something
is this looks like a lift
oh it looks like it's just something
easier to help
carry
the objects
let's go around because we killed
everybody
can't kill any more people than we
killed killed everybody
my question to the chat is
should i uh
should i continue killing people
maybe i should make the stream a little
bit more entertaining
and not just
silent kill everyone
like this dude
he saw something
you didn't see nothing
didn't see nothing
oh
man it's too easy it's too easy
shooting your way out is way too easy so
far
it's got to be something else that's
going to stop me from doing this over
and over again
i think probably the more you do stuff
that's uh
high profile
well they called it chaos and um
and previous dishonors
oh god there's a lot of people in here
no
oh locked
oh i missed you
yes
[Music]
alarms and scouts
bright and strong paint down their body
can trigger beef alarms will handle
their radius
when this happens rifle oh
oh my god
oh i got that reprise thing i forgot
about that
dying a third time will end your current
loop
all right so they did take me out of the
battle a little bit
don't need it
your health is going down rather quickly
yeah come in here i saw you
ready you and me
man this thing is crazy
[Music]
i think i missed him
not that time
give me a 50 cal seems like
this thing don't have a whole lot
of precautions man but you saw they
outnumbered me there pretty well
so i'm i'm assuming that's how they're
going to combat this
because these mutant stations are
everywhere
see i literally just got ammo i think
that's an issue
that's just me i think they give you too
much ammo in this game
nails
what's going on up here
shoot them all chaos freedom
food sucks
all right so let's go a little stealth
wise one thing i've never really liked
about a lot of stealth games is there's
no way they didn't hear those those
those shots in the other room
so to me it's kind of weird that you
know they're so
relaxed up here when they shouldn't be
yeah let's take one of these
take two
get that full health
oh my god
i don't even know how she saw me
get that health real quick
let's relocate
where did home girl go
[Music]
i guess we fighting
[Music]
deploy it
deploy
here
i'm trying to figure out how to use that
okay okay
all right
probably use against your enemies press
to
pick them up all right so there was two
over here
let's pick both of them up
hold to deploy okay
we're gonna deploy this
there we go
i like those those are cool
let's see if i can take one hold up
see if i can take one with me if i carry
it off the map out of that
that doesn't look like it's gonna let me
four two three zero
all right now let's pick it up
where to go
i gotta put it in again four two three
zero
we taking this
we might need this
what is this
hold up
what is this
what's going on
pick it up high
uh i attempted to but i didn't know how
it doesn't look like they're gonna let
me pick whatever that is up
all right let's grab this back though
yeah let's blow this joint
what's good
it's good man
uh
the lpp
it's in the security office so it's
going to be worth keeping you know
to get 2k
instantly removed it
man you should probably picked up that
ps5 you probably could have sold it
or sold 2k at least
this is the loop control center all
right
i do like how everything changes
depending on what's going on it does
feel
pretty you know
pretty worth it
[Music]
all right so i didn't pick up anything
die twice and come back die third time
and the day restarts
all right so let's see here
we definitely want this this this is
this is where it's at we definitely want
this
read your tinker
nah we gotta take that off where is that
we need that tinker
no you're gonna quit i just want the
tinker there you go
uh tinker
all right there we go
let's explore the rock
gotta wait for the game to be in game
pass i'm probably coughing trying to get
a ps5 for
uh or pc is the only question
i'm a drinker occasionally a drunk man
about island everyone knows me everyone
hates me handy with a gun quick with a
joke i dress well and why the [ __ ] is
everyone wearing a mask
it's a heck of a jig i'm done playing
this your way it's the cult show from
now on
i really like that girl
i said colt show not colt
[ __ ] it next stop i really like that
chick man i really like that chick she
gives this game
a nice
a nice thing man is that a map
no it's on a map i could really use a
map
okay
just down the road
the aon security system so sick of it
all
hold up
kind of like how they
how they disappear a little bit
i don't know i feel like the gun
mechanics is a little bit too extra
because i feel like this is mad easy man
it's mad easy just to get rid of things
like this like
i do feel like
they need to be a little bit more
strict when it comes to shooting stuff
no i wasn't did they i think i saw
something on twitter but i was preparing
for the stream so i didn't really have
time to go in there and look
down by the
this is a pretty docks group i feel like
shooting in this game's a little bit too
old
[Music]
kind of ruins like
the
makes it
i mean let's see if we could kill both
of these without them even noticing
well they'll notice
[Music]
see i mean that was just
i do feel like that's a little bit too
easy
oh that's a turret
i mean that's not even really an issue
either
[Music]
let's take this
hold up
i don't know what's going to come out so
let's deploy it here
it's my turret now
all right so
hack me okay
okay i didn't mean to do that
that was an accident
[Music]
are you gonna reload
does these things like
charge or something
i don't know
div i just released a video what did
they reach the video on
guys got to keep you up to date man
captain my captain uh captain my captain
my colt you want to hear safe to be here
say for now it is here is a safe enough
on the flight except miss mia told me
you left the gold default
is that an invitation everybody knows
those numbers that three six
three six three and five ellie got them
tattooed above her
left hip and the co to her heart maybe
probably you should tweak and send it
uh
tweak it and a number here and uh
another there until it's all again new
or whatever i threw all my numbers out
splash
okay so i don't know what that means
i'll knowledge progress you have often
returned to the location armed with new
information and now that you found the
code to your safe for example you can
head back to the flat and up down and
crack that bait that's safe over
remember that there was that um safe
that was there so now when i go there
i'm able to get in there
wait a [ __ ] second i made the lpp
which means
it's in my flat
back and [ __ ] abdom but i mean
is that gonna shoot me because it's blue
let's just go ahead and turn that off
[Music]
i ain't trying to have no issues
oh
i think that's some [ __ ]
what is this
yeah yeah i see i'm an idiot
i just died for no reason
come on there you go
i mean i've pretty much killed everybody
in this area
so it's not like there's ever going to
be anyone to shoot me unless they
replenish the
the people which
it's very possible they could
all right so four two three zero
right so here we go
let's blow this joint
the captain turns out you were kind of a
big deal on black reef but that just
makes people want to kill you harder
all right there we go
logging in the game server
all right so let's see here
you've survived you drowned so i did die
once unfortunately that was my stupidity
i um
i need to go back to his place and open
that stream
and open that safe now since i got the
actual thing to do it with now
so here's the map
leave the most informative these are the
most important information on blackroot
the keys to defeating visionaries and
breaking the loop each lead off uh
offers step-by-step instructions by uh
for overcoming your enemies call
retrains the discovery within the lead
across loops by selecting a lead you can
activate markers leading to your
objective and
additional guidance on the mission
select screen
okay
first rock
have you referenced back to the
documents you discovered
notes are uh text-based pages found
across across the islands
uh include audio recordings of okay so
it's pretty much just
more information i don't really need
right now
but we got to go back in and open that
up
how is the game it runs pretty smooth
i'm not having issues but i am on um
i am on playstation right on pc
uh another gentleman in the chat was
saying it was running pretty bad on pc
so
something something different
juliana
juliana there she's coming to kill me
now
i remember your name
oh julian is coming to kill me now
i'm i'm very
very nervous now
freestyle up dom this whole place is
connected to those tunnels
i'm scared that
all right so you can't do that hey guys
i have top secret information okay what
is it i said it was top secret spill it
[ __ ] okay okay
the best place to see the fireworks is
next to the state next to the stage why
is that that's all you've got please
don't yeah that was pretty lame it's
gonna be spectacular i'm freezing my ass
off looking for colts
very [ __ ] spectacular we should take
them alive and strap into the firework
trying to open the door got their
attention
i guess it does kind of make a little
bit of a sound
when in doubt shoot them with this gun
take them out
looks like i can get up a little bit
above them
let's try that
there's one
i think that's the chick that had the
ow
let's take out this dude
oh my god you can see me
pop your head out
you're just never gonna
oh i can't believe i just did that
[Music]
congratulations on getting invited guys
what is going
on who is this
[Music]
all right so there's no point in
shooting this yet
yeah it snapped his back pretty good man
we should be able to wait for him just
to come back one more thing
how can he see me
oh god
all right all right let's go
oh that dude up there got my number
i don't know how he saw me
oh this might be a wrap for this play
through
why did i dad shoot
all right so i'm up here now
so they think they killed me i'm pretty
sure so i think i should be fine
they think they got me you guys they
didn't though
yeah tj there was a lot of people there
man i'm not gonna front there was a lot
of people there
there wasn't a lot of things i could
have done there
you know maybe not get seen that would
have been something good
no i cannot be seen again
let's go and handle him
yeah see
we got to be more stealth like man we
got to be more stealthwise
because i don't think we'll be able to
fight this dude without being stealth
alright so
let's go ahead and kill these two
let's get them out of the way
that's
dead
all right come on
so we got rid of them too
now we should be able to use our double
jump and get back up here yeah
now we killed that dude this time so we
don't have to worry about him
let's kill the dude up at the top right
i feel like he's gonna be an issue
yeah see he's already seeing us
i feel like if we don't kill him first
he's gonna see anyone we take down
oh my god
stop moving
can i not kill him
okay did anyone see
i mean i shot him like three times he
didn't get he didn't get a shot off
though he didn't get a shot off i think
we're good
i'm still nervous so
let's get rid of him
so there's no one below us
there's no one below us we should be
fine
i don't think we have
no we don't have that
okay so
we should be able to go for this dude
here
wait wait for it
no
missed
oh i suck no i'm not even shooting it
did she see me
i only got 12 shots left
all right so we're good there
what is this
got a new gun
it's a little bit
i mean things get serious we could use
that gun but i don't think we're going
to use that gun
we're going to use this
so we got her
we're running out of nails though we are
definitely running out of nails
it's a health station i don't need one
though
i ain't been seen since i died
there's that door station again
all right so now they got one over here
oh that's
let's get rid of that
so we turned it to our side
okay he did
where is he
all right so are you used all that
yeah i like that he did he didn't
acknowledge that i was dead
that's that's a nice little thing he
acknowledged that i was dead
i think we're good here
so
joint
took your precious lpp i'm too smart too
fast too powerful and you're just slow
and boring as ever
i'm not even mad about it just
disappointed i know you could do better
or you could go [ __ ] yourself which
whichever you're called love julian
not feeling how she took it man
we went through all that trouble to get
to here and she took it
you don't call me
so i'll just do your thing then what was
that writing hacky [ __ ] for a bunch
of dick bags
looks like somebody came by to say hi
i'm not finished i lock the door so the
tv can get acquainted what
little tunnels brilliant
really
julian's invasion julian may enter a
district to hunt you down will julian
invade your game the tonal exits are
locked and
unlock them by hacking the local radio
antenna you can also take julian on
replenish your repos by defeating her
julian only invades districts where our
visionary is present
and you can only be invaded to a limited
number of times per loop okay so
julian's somewhere around here and i'm
kind of scared of her
[Music]
that's julian there i still hacked the
intent
where's julian
i'm scared to leave
slabs julian and most of which carry
slabs that carry superman you can use
them
but you first have to take them off
their course
i'm not trying to kill one right now
oh julian's right there
reloading
we out we ain't messing with julia
we out
julian is where i draw the line
we out
julian will rock my world
we ain't fighting julian
we're gonna slide straight in here
we out
wasn't risking it man didn't have a
whole i think i have one reprise left
wasn't gonna risk her killing me was it
just was not gonna happen
yeah i told julian deuces i was like i'm
out well i'm out
i like how they tell me she survived
right here
so i collected that
you made it through the day
started another day
it's what's up man i like that that's a
nice little thing
all right
it'll be pretty oh so it starts the
whole day gotta get to the safe before
and then i got the lpp
i don't know better be a gun
okay so i got to get to the lp people
for sure [ __ ] [ __ ]
my weapons are
gone
all right so let's go straight for the
safe because i think that's the best
thing for us to do
we're not playing with you same day
which means i already know what's going
to happen yeah
and i'm sick of waking up on this
[ __ ] yeah what it's totally
[Music]
ashamed i normally to break it to you
but there is nothing normal about this
[ __ ] act you see that's why i can't
let you destroy it it's special you got
me the first time and the second
you know what they say you know
we're going straight for that we're
going straight for it there's no
murderous children on this island
[Music]
four two three zero
we're going straight for our house
we got the code
we're going straight for it
all right hit the apartment hard
get the safe
lpp
uh break the move
let's go
i like that
i don't feel like the animation should
go over the clothing it should go like
in the front of the shirt like like
right here and go back because i felt
like it's a little sloppy just going
over the fabric
if that makes sense to you guys i know
probably probably being too much
was that a player or was the first time
you come across julian
was that
just i wonder if the first time you come
across julian
is is is a computer
all right so at night it's a little bit
different because at night if you guys
remember there was there was stuff that
was stopping me from going here that i
had to crawl under and this place right
here this this door here was blocked
so that's that's definitely interesting
how they've done that
but we're going this way we're not going
up there
going through that doorway is kind of
stupid
oh [ __ ] did not mean to do
that right so let's go ahead and handle
that
all right so
let me see if i can
get to my flat pretty easily during the
day
might not be as many people hearing
today
the
library what is that
i'm not trying to get seen by everybody
that'd be horrible by everybody
i feel like what's going on there like
something's bigger going on with julian
yeah they had stuff completely changed
the other day
let's pack
[Music]
all right so remember last time we came
here
there was these two people were here so
we can easily take these people out
because we've done it before
um
i'm not to stop doing that because that
hurts my neck just seeing that
all right lpp show you something good
six
three
five
that is not what i wanted
all right so
the loop preservation protocol
how is this game bro so far so good
um
okay mega you know i've been enjoying it
man
uh there are loot it pursues only as
long as they survive so that's why
they're saying that there's people that
we have to assassinate looks like is the
visionaries are part of the loop and you
have to kill them all to stop the loop
so far i don't know you any threat to
the visionaries is a threat to the loop
so i'm a threat to the visionaries
because i want to kill them in the loop
uh if
no more parties no more experiments no
more eternal life so they consider this
eternal life because you're reliving the
same day over and over again which is
kind of weird
protocol while analyzing your interest
offices and residents i've i i've
identified
significant points of weakness for each
visionaire oh so they're telling you
the weaknesses to every person
all right so
large gatherings at dorsey matter up
damn
that is pretty much saying look you guys
are being too predictable you need to
stop
charlie overseeing his live-action game
up then
everywhere solidaire evening at starling
laps so the evening he seems to be at
the
starling labs the sarling labs
when you go for the assassinations and
you turn the option on these players can
be real players oh that's cool
uh generally
up damn
in the in the in the case of a security
event esoterics would be directed
towards the listing vulnerabilities
visionaries
should avoid close contact with one
another until the crisis is resolved
uh obviously the responsibility of
hunting the
and eliminating
is the head of security aka yours truly
so i'm ahead of security so i made this
this is how i'm going to break the loop
all right eight people one day that's
smarter than it sounds you yup oh all
right so so what's the plan eight
targets one day we're going to need a
couple more colts in here if we're going
to wreck this island in a culture what
no listen i can't stay long how did you
even get in here didn't you get shot two
loops ago or was it three
so many different goals look there's
thousands of us or more i i don't know
but none of us have gotten it right okay
you've got to be better than all of us
so don't just try to shoot everything
but i like shooting you gotta be smart
it's the only way to fix this
this
and this
i prefer the cold storm plan g's lab
figure out residual it'll make your life
easier
or do it the hard way
whatever hand holding is over what what
are you looking at
so they're pretty much saying tutorials
over here [ __ ]
all right
let's get started
wengie's lab huh
lpp said it was back at the complex
frank
all right so
i assume this is
where now this is the port of the game
where we actually look for these people
break the loop kill all eight
visionaries
chaos theory
lost in transmission space invader
so this is pretty much just telling you
where they are
the lead is tracked
these are the eight these are some of
the eight people i assume
arsenal leads
all right so we discovered a map
there's only so many hours before the
festivities tonight so get outside and
have something this is the
all right so
let's track this lead
so you guys know what time it is
so i wonder if they could if they invade
you on the third day
well
after the night
so we're not going to really look too
much into this
i wonder why i don't have the ability to
the double jump ability anymore
four three
four two three zero
all right so
out of his world
noon day charlie
good music in his crib frank spencer
morning
oh this is
giving you like
i assume
hints to where they are
and his la in his lab every afternoon
weenie
edgar and alec alexis
night time is the right time
the complex for the nut job rich kind in
his
apartment
okay so
lunch time in the frisk rock
has been kidnapped show your support and
lock him up
please
what about the julie where is she
everywhere but everywhere but where
all right so pretty much
we gotta kill
eight people in one day
they i assume when you kill the first
one the rest are gonna be on high alert
or maybe if you i don't know they seem
pretty important i feel like
they're going to know if you kill the
others
all right
the luke preservation protocol a bunch
of big words to make a simple point
i kill every visionary in one day i
break the loop period i know where they
spend time but i'm guessing it won't be
as easy as hunting them down
good thing i'm one stubborn [ __ ]
all right so by finding the loop and
establishing the locations of the
visionaries you've completed the lead
the longest day now if you remember
correctly back at the beginning of this
stream we couldn't
do certain things until you completed
the longest time pretty sure it was the
multiplayer thing
uh time on blueprint is divided into
four periods morning noon afternoon and
evening the periods don't advance while
you're in a district so feel free to
take your time throughout uh thoroughly
to explore so pretty much they don't
exceed as long as you're in that
district the moment you go back to the
hub world that's when it's going to
carry on to whenever the next one is
it's new now in the past you visited the
complex at noon
later you've been able to return the
complex at noon or you could check the
uh out up damn or frogs instead
districts often uh offer different
opportunities and challenges here in
different periods of time for instance
they said we went to the complex at nude
so maybe we go to foxbridge or whatever
that place is called
at nude instead so i'm assuming you know
things will change depending on what you
do
doctor women's land is only open for
experiments in the afternoon for example
if you're going to
toss the place like that other coat
suggested you have to do it then so i'd
have to go at night to complex maybe get
a passcode maybe get some kind of
information right get there during the
day at a different time
i assume
uh i don't know i'm not on pc i don't
know if it has um
any form of controller support
this is not only displays the current
time but also allows you to move between
time periods
even on black reef times move uh times
moves mostly forward from morning to
noon to afternoon to evening morning
comes after night obviously but due to
the loop it all is it's always the
morning before
it's new now so with this time hold x
and you can
uh wait to the afternoon
you know it'll automatically change
all right so let's go
oh so you don't keep stuff
it's interesting
personal touch double jump
baron said you're quicker and lets you
uh
and you kick like a mule
always down to kick like a mule
[Music]
so now we gotta go to this lap i don't
know what's up this lap but we're gonna
go to this lab
probably going to do this live thing and
call it for the stream
because
i definitely want to get ready for
attitude
even when i'm not
how do i keep my weapons against
the infusion
this infusion keeps sounding better and
better i
don't like how i don't have that anymore
i don't even remember where i got that
nail gun
let's knock this dude out
of there
all right so we should be good
i don't like the
designs they use for people i don't like
the fact that they disappear either sure
i feel like if i get any closer that the
thing's going to murk me
all right so i got to get up there and
get that person taken care of
all right so you can see me up there
let's wait for them to turn around
oh my god
are you going to turn around again
you don't turn around very long do you
what
okay
gotta wait a little bit
what is this
let's take that
okay so i gotta go big i'll have this on
me
all right maybe there's like a way i can
go over here
no i'm pretty sure i'll
breathe down there
oh god oh god oh god oh god
gotta get you up out of here
the ass end of everything okay so let's
see what's going on over here
there's uh
i don't really i'm not really feeling
that i'm not gonna lie
safety for a moment
can't reach that
i'm not trying to get seen either
let's go this way
my local library is 10 coffee's coming
friday i reserved
libraries still ran out games
that's interesting
i remember uh they did that with like
the old xboxes where i am
[Music]
the last time i came here
all right so there's one here
let's get rid of this one real quick
what the [ __ ] where's that light
going what's going on
i'm confused
deadly containment something's going on
here if you remember correctly we came
here at a different time frame and all
these doors were locked for some reason
but what they aren't are you saying that
we are capable of inferior
not all but
my new fluctuations
i was hoping i could shut the door
it doesn't look like i can though
all right
bringing the vessel here from the
control room
is i'm so nervous
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know what's going on this is so
weird
i assume they're connected
unforgivable and then it's just that
upside down
okay so
it's just a bunch of them
are they clones
is she like transporting herself to her
like conscious and other people
what are you saying about the game
um
so far so good i'll give it a good
in-depth analysis on uh iop
all right so
she
fell away
to break her consciousness up
into other people we're talking and the
clock is ticking
you coming over here
[Music]
i think i think she's cloned herself
multiple times and the only way to get
rid of her is to get rid of all the
clones
i don't know i'm very confused
try again tomorrow
this is weird
i guess we're gonna
try to one hit one like this
[Music]
what is going on
there's a lot of them
all right so let's go back into that
other section
i'm confused
each video contains significant but
harvesting process
to test during preaching uh experiment
semi successful
killing every vision of myself would be
producers for invasion but it but then
i'll be dead okay so you have to kill
them all
all right so we got to kill them all
an observation from this morning's early
announcements the notable leap in the
skill and proficiency of eternalists
cult and juliana
yes
you gotta go to the other
no one bring
these early
trinkets across
[Music]
there's one down there in that building
all right so
gotta scramble it
all right i'm liking the game so far i
wouldn't even know where to begin
this is an important experiment
[Music]
visitors
is there more in here
first a sleek personal tricking
and the four pounder
what is this
a keypad so we need some kind of keypad
that we'll probably get from her later
the relevant security cuts may be in a
different location than in your timeline
mine on the bottom section of lab nx
i gotta find a way to get over there
all right so it looks like there's one
last one
where's the last one
you gotta be kidding me
[Music]
so visionary's dead
[Music]
is she gonna disappear
so i don't know
the codes to these
all right lockdown codes 2162
[Music]
all right so we gotta find wherever that
is
already got full ammo
let's go in here and see if we can find
that computer so
all right let's figure this [ __ ] out
i kill all the wedgies and i can use
this thing to collect the residum i need
to get her machine running that makes
sense yeah all right so
i gotta go back to the final one
do i even want this [ __ ] trick
science it's
like vacuuming all right so i i captured
her essence i guess that's what you'd
call it
i like how i got that cold though that
code's gonna be really helpful in the
future we need that code
oh right there now just get in this tube
shower thing and
press the button
like this [ __ ] am i supposed to do that
stand on the plate shoot the button
all right science let's dance
i will shoot some ass pieces
oh god what's going on
what did i just do
did i just kill myself
[Music]
death is a small price to pay to hold on
to your gear
or so i guess that when i die i hold on
to my gear and i don't have to like go
find it again because that is kind of
annoying to have to go look for yourself
the looks was better than a fort i think
uh it's f it's good so i died once
due to
falling off the cliff that we won't talk
about ever again we won't bring that up
and then i died again because i had to
sacrifice myself to
to use that ability
the key to access the different controls
in the arena lab so i got that that's
going to be really helpful in the future
there are districts i've
missed it
arizona you can now spin it into
to infuse weapons crickets and slabs
allowing you to keep them across loops
each fusion
piece of gear will be returned to your
arsenal every morning
harvest from infused objects across
blackville from the glitches left behind
by dead visionaries
you can also sacrifice weapons trickets
and slabs to gather more residue
you cannot transfer a resident between
loops so be sure to spend it so you it
doesn't carry over is that playing on
the pa i'm playing on the ps5
when you
when you die
and rip ride you drop your current
recent
at the place of your death indicated by
marker however if you run out
in the day loops all residue is lost
okay
it's lat no it's lost
oh yeah it [ __ ] it actually actually
worked who's the super scientist now
you and me baby together forever
at least until i break this loop
all right so now
we got what we need we know how to kill
her so we could get her up out of there
if we had to
so and she can be done the afternoon but
i'm assuming now since we have the
lockdown codes who should i call you we
might be able to get a gun feels a bit
uh
formal
gunter
gonna slave
maybe
the machine yeah
all right
all right so probably gonna call it here
you guys
appreciate you guys coming through
trying out this new stream i'm hoping
you guys like the quality of the stream
uh i do think
from what i look it looks fine uh you
know got the new camera
got the new
pc um you know everything looks seems to
be coming through i've got a semi new
mic
everything seems to be decent so we're
going to go ahead and in the stream here
if i do pick up the stream it's probably
going to be on the twitch channel i
don't know yet usually i'm just probably
going to start every new game on twitch
i mean on youtube
and then we'll go to twitch i don't know
yet though but
appreciate everyone coming out this is
gaming out of time out here peace